(Audience applause)
♪♪
Man:
On the northeast tip of
North America...
♪♪
is a town called Gander.
September 11th, 2001.
Over 200 planes getting
diverted.
♪♪
Even with all the hotels in town
we've got no room.
With thousands of passengers
arriving at any minute,
Lady:
the town is asking for help
with...
Lady:
well anything you can do!
♪♪
We barely know where we are!
I'm just freaking out, I wish I
was home.
Thank you for shopping at
Walmart.
Would you like to come back to
my house for a shower?
(Audience laughs)
♪♪
Hello? Yes, it's me.
Dad, I'm okay.
♪In the middle of who knows,
who knows where♪
♪You'll find♪
♪Something in the middle of
nowhere♪
♪In the middle of clear blue
air♪
We honor what was lost, but we
also commemorate what we found.
♪♪
(Audience applause)